very good greetings this is our inaugural uh evening lockdown meditation and i want to thank you all for coming both of you so uh i want to first of all uh just start by thanking charles denscombe who runs a firm called video uh micro video and uh paul ebray who's is uh who works with him and uh they really
set me up for this very quickly, so I'm really grateful.
I'm also feedbacking on one of their channels, so I'm even more grateful.
Now, unfortunately, the screen isn't very good because I've got a cheapo laptop here working on that.
I have bought a proper camera and things like that, but it's just not arrived.
The post is all over the place at the moment, as I'm sure you're aware of.
Audience just come in to tell me to speak up a bit louder.
So you can tell me if I'm not speaking loud enough.
I think there's a sort of a, you can say something on the stream here, the live chat.
I'm here too.
You're all here.
Thank you so much.
Oh, I feel much better now.
Oh, even, yeah, it's all wonderful.
So I hope you've got my opening gambit there to thank Charles Denscombe and Paul Ebray.
Oh, very good.
Sounds coming across very clearly.
I've just had a little message.
Thank you very much.
So what I want to do this evening is just set the process off.
The first question is, you know, why have I chosen an evening meditation?
So I'm just going back to my own experience as a lay practitioner.
And it was fairly easy to establish the morning meditation.
In fact, that was almost, I rarely missed it.
There'd be a good reason for missing it.
You just get into that routine, you get up, you wash your face, and then you sit, and then you go and have breakfast.
And that I think most people find fairly simple to establish.
No matter for how long, it doesn't matter how long.
It's the quality, isn't it?
20 minutes, 40 minutes, one hour, two hours if you can make it.
Well, you know.
But the evening sit was always very difficult.
By the way, I can see myself talking to myself.
It was a very strange situation.
So the evening sit was always difficult.
But of course, when I did do it, I saw the benefits of it.
If you're working,
I found that the best time was when you get home and you have a cup of tea or something, and then just to sit in a chair, you don't have to sit formally and just let the day pass through the mind.
If it's been a good day and you feel full of joy, then really appreciate that and see where you've been skillful and encourage yourself to be more skillful like that.
And when you've had a bad day, some arguments, some anxiety, he's been boring or whatever,
to come back and just let that let that manifest and let it sort of work its way out of the heart and that way you feel so much better for the evening and uh and then of course later on uh just before you go to bed to just sit quietly with something some reading uh meta of course that's the time you tend to fall asleep and you don't want to fall asleep before you get into bed because that messes you up knowing that does so if you're working it's a slightly different rhythm i think that works
as opposed to this.
This is really aimed at people who are isolating, like myself.
I am actually in splendid solitude.
So I'm not concerned about lockdown at all.
In fact, I'd be happy if it was a permanent state.
I have with me now, actually, Sarah Blackman from the South.
People in Brighton will know Sarah.
And Noreen is with me.
Mark had visited us on last Friday and then discovered later on that he'd been eight hours working with somebody who had contracted CV.
So we're in isolation here till next Friday.
And Mark's had no symptoms.
We've had no symptoms, so we think we're fairly free.
At least we're okay till tomorrow.
now uh when you're in isolation of course and you know in in in the spiritual life you call it seclusion you know you seek seclusion you seek uh you seek um uh solitude uh now of course you'll know that if you're if you're a naughty prisoner you get put into solitary confinement so so you can see it can be used both as a as a way of um a spiritual practice and as a way of
of actually punishing somebody.
So we've got to be careful that we don't see it as a punishment.
So evening, of course, we tend to feel a bit tired.
We tend to feel a bit bored or whatnot.
We're looking to distract ourselves.
And so this is the time, the evil one, Mara, the enticer, sort of gets hold of us and we get into old habits.
habits that we don't want.
We sleep, for instance, which is really messes your sleep pattern up.
We eat, you know, butter toast and things like that, you know, with jam.
Oh, my God.
So you can find yourself slipping into old habits which really are not going to do you much good.
So to actually set a time in the evening where you sit obviously is the best policy.
And that's why I chose this particular time because I'm hoping that afterwards most of you who are in isolation will actually go to bed and rise early.
As they say, what is it?
Early to bed and early to rise makes a man healthy, wealthy, and wise.
And I presume that's also true for women.
It's an old one, yeah.
So we've got to be careful in the evening.
The old ghosts come out.
So there's anxiety.
uh depression a bit of feeling down rather than depression and uh and and we want to escape that so that's why we that's why we try to find some entertainment and whatnot so uh the idea of this particular meditation at this time of night this time of the evening is to stop that happening and i'm hoping that you make it a regular practice with me so that's the first thing
There are practices that you can do which undermine certain mental states, sense of despair, for instance, even boredom.
It doesn't matter really what mental state it is, unwholesome mental state, really just contemplating the Buddha Dharma Sangha is one way of lifting the heart.
The Buddha, of course, is this historical personage
but also you know really recognizing that within us the buddha is here within within us and it's seeking liberation and according to the buddhist tradition everybody will you know attain liberation at some point or other uh and the dharma just think about the benefits that you've you've received from the dharma
the benefits that others have received it lifts the heart you know and the sangha uh the fact that we've uh we have people in the world who've attained some of these paths and fruits uh but also that we have a sangha around us friends dharma friends around us you know supporting us and and these days that's uh that can be a real benefit especially with all this communication business uh we've just had an agm this afternoon and um
We used teams and it was pretty successful.
So there's no reason why we can't communicate with each other these days.
Of course, relating is a different matter.
But we won't go into that this evening.
The other thing, of course, is to contemplate the Brahma Viharas, love, compassion, joy and peace.
And that's what I'll be doing at the end of the sitting this evening.
But we'll come to that.
There's also, you know, sort of contemplations of sickness, aging and death.
It sounds a bit depressing to actually do that, but it's really coming to terms with the reality of our lives.
And something that this CV, this coronavirus has brought up is the paranoia that everybody feels around sickness, even though really it's the elderly
And even they have to have some sort of physical problems who are in real danger.
Of course, it is killing others, but very minor.
Even so, even if you could describe it as a very, very bad flu, people are, you know, very afraid of it.
Of course, having said that, I know a lot of people need hospital help for breathing and stuff.
So I'm not saying we shouldn't take it seriously.
but the paranoia is, you know, it's sort of way up there.
And we undermine that sort of unrealistic paranoia by reflecting that the body gets sick, you know, and eventually we die, and that's the end of it.
It's just one of those things.
Also, there's the eight worldly conditions, contemplating sickness and health,
uh contemplating uh success and failure fame and disgrace uh praise and blame pleasure and pain and just knowing that these things flow they flow from one to sometimes you're successful and sometimes and sometimes you fail that's the way it is it life life just moves through that and it's finding that position above it all a sort of an equanimity with it you know and then finally there's this um oh sorry the other way of course is vipassana
So it's really just sitting with the mental state that comes up, knowing it is just another mental state and sitting in it, yeah?
You've got to sit in the bonfire.
You've got to sit in the dung heap, not next to it, not above it or around it, but in it, right?
You've got to sit in and you've got to burn.
And, of course, we wait, if you can wait, until it completely
exhausted, then you find that healing at the end of it.
Yeah, this happened to me in the year 2000 when I went on a two month retreat to Burma to Sidhu Pandita's place in Yangon.
And the six weeks were some of the worst meditations I've had ever.
It was absolutely awful.
Something came up.
I couldn't put my finger on it.
It wasn't despair or anything like that.
It was just horrible.
and i couldn't even i couldn't do the slow walking meditation it was just so overpowering and after six weeks it finally just disappeared and uh and the gift of course was this beautiful state of peace that arises so if you can wait until these negative states exhaust themselves you do see that they're being transformed so that's that
So there's contemplating the Buddha, Dharma, Sangha, the virtues, I've forgotten that, the eight worldly conditions and so on.
There's contemplating sickness, aging, and death, just to get us into the feel of these things.
And there's the practice of vipassana and metta.
So that's the first thing.
That's what you can do to undermine
mental states, unwholesome mental states in the evening.
The next one is the importance of routines.
I can't stress that too much.
As you know, when you come on retreat, you've got to get into that routine.
It takes three or four days and then you're into it, you know.
And after five or six days, it's sort of natural.
Even if you don't want to get out of bed, your body gets out.
So it's that sort of routine that you want to establish.
And make it simple, you know.
Remember Ajahn Tate's words, take it easy.
Make it simple, take it easy, and stay with the one who knows.
There are things, you've got to do it religiously, remember.
Once you've set your routine for the day, you've got to do it religiously until you know it's become a habit.
And that takes maybe four or five days.
And then if you slip,
You've got to reestablish it.
You've got to reestablish your commitment to that routine.
It's not as though you can't change the routine, but you've got to recognize that you've got to make it some sort of habit.
One thing that you can do, of course, is go a bit slower around the place.
Slow eating.
Slow eating, yeah?
You're supposed to chew the food 32 times.
That's what I read on Google.
32 times until it loses its texture.
It's sort of pre-vomit.
Oh, I shouldn't have said that.
I'm sorry.
It's before it goes into the stomach.
Remember, the stomach doesn't have any teeth.
So if you put hard stuff in there, it's going to be difficult.
Closing fridge doors, you know, closing doors, you know, just to bring a certain mindfulness, a slowness and mindfulness around whatever you're doing.
So that's the routine.
That's important.
The third thing is projects.
You've got to have projects.
They can be a day's project, a week's project, et cetera, et cetera.
I mean, I've set myself one.
I'm going to reread as much as I can of the middle-end sayings.
And in the evening, if there aren't any questions, I mean to sort of use that as a way of giving a small talk or something.
My brother, for instance, has taken on...
practicing the piano so you can get the next grade so it really is anything anything that you can feel you can commit to something that you wanted to do but you've never got around to doing it a new skill learn a language and there's all this free stuff that you can access on on the website so it really is quite quite simple to get yourself um excited about something
The final thing is exercise.
Yeah, you've got to keep your exercise going.
And if you're confined to a space, then that's really quite important.
When I was practicing in Burma, I didn't do any exercise for about six months and I lost muscle.
I felt really, really weak.
I determined to find something that would give me just that little bit of muscle tone.
and what i discovered were the canadian air force exercises which were sort of um famous at the time uh i i i mean basically you just within the space of your own body you do push-ups press-ups uh jump-ups and all sorts of ups and uh and and that keeps you going running on the spot things like that uh the one thing that they showed you was straight legs if you do sit-ups or that is a that is a killer don't do that at all bend your legs
That's one of the reasons I've got a bad back.
I didn't get around to suing them.
But if you go on there, there's all sorts of things.
You can do some shadow boxing.
Yeah, just get it out of the system.
Jog around the room.
In one retreat I was in, the only real, because it was in North America, and it was at the Forest Refuge, and it was during winter, and it was on minus 20 or something, you know.
So the morning when I used to run up, I used to walk up and down stairs.
And that was that was pretty good.
Anyway, again, if you go on to the websites, you've got all sorts of suggestions.
There's one for cardio workout for small places.
And there's one that he he suggested, which is called a burpee.
So I looked that one up, a burpee, that sounds interesting.
And this is what you do.
You have to stand upright, you see, stand upright with your arms to your side and your feet apart.
And then you lower your body into a squat, got it?
And then you sort of put your hands on the floor and you kick back so that your body is straight, right?
Straight and you do a push up.
and then you sneak back into you jump back into a squat and then you it says explosively jump into the air and when you land you die no no when you land you go back into a squat and you do the whole thing again so i'll try and build up to that over the uh two months a bit of luck so so uh with those little pointers in mind i'm probably teaching grandmother how to suck eggs but sometimes it's worth saying the obvious
That's my inaugural encouragement to use this time, especially if you are in real lockdown, people who've got physical problems.
Roy, for instance, who's done all our work here on the ground, digging the trenches, putting in the septic tank and all that, he doesn't have any kidneys.
And so he's basically locked into his home.
So there are many people like that.
And, uh, I know some of the people who come here to like that.
So, you know, I'm, I'm aiming, uh, a great deal of this towards them, but it also works with people for, for those of you are working and you have to go out, uh, to come back and, um, come and join us in the evening.
Okay.
So we're moving up to eight 19.
Um, I just want to say what I mean to do this evening.
I hope you were able to download the evening contemplations.
Yeah.
So I'm going to start with the refuge and precepts and then I'm going to do the evening meditations.
So this is what we do here on retreat, of course, the old sickness, aging and death.
Can't get away from it.
And then towards the end, at the end, I'll spend about 15 minutes or so just going through the Brahma Viharas.
First of all, compassion, then joy, and then metta.
Equanimity, I'm presuming, is sustained underneath it.
And I shall read out the discourse on loving kindness and then chant.
Now, during that chant, some of you know the chant, so you can chant along.
Chant along a monk, you see.
You sit along a monk and you can chant along a monk.
So you can do that or, you know, just put some good intentions into your heart.
May you be safe, well and happy.
The ones that we use here, may you be safe, well and happy.
May all beings be safe, well and happy.
You can bring individuals to mind and just use it to express your loving kindness.
So I think...
We're sort of getting there.
Right.
Well, I've done my inaugural speech and whatnot.
And I'm just wondering if there's any questions that have come up about that.
I see there's lots of people have joined us.
Nice comments.
Thank you very much.
So we have somebody from Sweden and Italy.
Oh, yes.
you're on the on the continent of course then you're one hour ahead of us so it's actually past nine really what might be possible if you don't want to stay up that long is that eventually I will have the meditation itself as a separate video and if you wanted to you could use that to encourage yourself and then at
eight o'clock which would be your nine o'clock uh you can join me live uh for whatever we um you know for the talk or for the discussion if you do want to um ask a question it's it would be good if you emailed it me in the morning or sometime uh during the day definitely before six o'clock or then five o'clock really uh and then it gives me time to um
to prepare some answer, because usually it comes off the top of my head, you know.
But it would be nice to prepare something.
So it's lovely to see.
I see everybody here.
That's very lovely.
Yes, so thank you all for coming.
That's fantastic.
So if you can, of course, stay with me every night.
But if you can't, at least come and join me when you can.
So unless there are...
I'm presuming everybody who's going to join has joined now.
So if there's any... unless there's an actual question, I shall then proceed to the meditation.
Yeah?
That's lovely.
I'm just looking at all the people who come and join.
Fantastic.
Surprisingly, I've got here 127.
That's not bad, is it?
I can see that, 127.
I might become famous at last.
so there's the offering every evening at eight o'clock uh some small talk or answering some questions and then um and then we'll start the sitting so join the sitting